okay let's start with the in the center
so when we're talking about the in
center what we're looking at are the
three angle bisectors so it's this ray
here is cutting this angle in half we
draw another angle bisector from this
vertex that's cutting this angle in half
and if we draw one more from the the
third vertex cutting that angle in half
what we have is this point right here
which is called the in-center and the
reason they call it the in-center is
because you can inscribe okay a circle
inside of the triangle such at the sides
of the triangle are tangent to the
circle now what does that mean when you
say that they're tangent to the circle
it means that you know they just barely
touch at one point but if you draw a
perpendicular okay a right angle okay
from that sin center that circle to the
sides of the triangle like this these
are going to be the radii of the circle
and what do you know about the lengths
of the radii of a circle they're all
congruent so if you can identify that
you're looking at the three angle
bisectors this point of concurrency as
it's called is referred to as the
in-center think of in describing the
circle inside and then you're going to
know that the three radii are congruent
now let's talk about the circumcenter so
when we talk about the circumcenter what
we're talking about here are the three
perpendicular bisectors so when you
think of perpendicular we think of at a
right angle right we think of a bisector
we think of it as cutting the side in
half or bisecting and so if we draw the
three perpendicular bisectors just if I
can draw this accurately here for us
okay what we end up with here this point
where all three of those perpendicular
bisectors cross is called the
circumcenter and the reason they call
the circumcenter is because what you can
do is you can circumscribe or draw a
circle around the triangle okay such
that the vertices of the triangle lie
right on the circle now what they're
going to ask you is something referring
to the lengths of the radii if you look
at this radius here and you look at the
radius here and you look at this radius
here all these radii are going to be
congruent because the reed a and a
circle are congruent now this isn't a
right triangle and so what you notice is
that the point of concurrency that
circumcenter is lying right on the
triangle okay so I'm just going to right
over here on let's look at what happens
when you have a an obtuse triangle like
this one here we draw the three
perpendicular bisectors so here's a
perpendicular bisector okay
perpendicular and cuts the side in half
let's see here's a perpendicular
bisector okay cuts this side in half and
let's see where's the third one it would
be somewhere like right about here okay
and it cuts this side in half now am i
drawing just a rough drawing here but
what you can understand is that when
it's that obtuse triangle like this is
at the point of concurrency that
circumcenter is going to be outside of
the triangle so when you go to draw the
circle around the triangle okay that
Center that circle is going to be
outside so we'll just write out for this
one and then for a acute triangle where
all the angles are less than 90 if we
draw the three perpendicular bisectors
okay what you notice is that point of
concurrency that circumcenter lies
inside the triangle so I'm just gonna
write in here now one thing to pay
attention to is that so you look at this
triangle over here notice that when I
drew the perpendicular bisectors it
doesn't the perpendicular bisector
doesn't necessarily go through the
opposite vertex now it happened to in
this triangle over here it also happened
over here in this triangle here but
that's not always the case you just want
to make sure that you go through the
midpoint of the side and perpendicular
and then we're those three cross that's
going to be your circumcenter for the
centroid what we're looking at are the
three medians so where do the three
medians cross that's the point of
conquer nsync all that point where they
cross the centroid but what you do with
the centroid is you go from the vertex
to the middle of the opposite side so
the median you think of middle so
these two are going to be congruent
we're going from the opposite vertex to
the opposite side that's one median
let's find the midpoint over here on
this side and draw that median and then
same thing over here let's find the
midpoint of this third side and draw
from the vertex to the opposite side
where those three points cross
that's our centroid and the important
thing to remember about the centroid is
that it's like the center center of mass
I was to cut this out here this triangle
and I could balance it right at this
point okay that's one key characteristic
the other key characteristic is that
we're okay this point crosses it divides
up the median into two pieces it's
dividing up into this portion right here
which is one third of the whole median
length and this other piece right here
which is two-thirds now how do you know
which is the one-third or two-thirds
piece well usually you can tell because
the one through pieces you know
obviously shorter but sometimes it's not
so easy to tell so when you're going
from the vertex towards the opposite
side that's going to be the two-thirds
portion and the from the side to the
centroid that's gonna be the one-third
portion so here if you see from this
vertex see that's two-thirds one-third
now just to make us a little bit more
concrete say that the length of this
meeting was like 27 all we'd have to do
is multiply 27 times one-third or divide
it by three we would know that this
length is nine we could then double it
because two-thirds is double one-third
and we then know this length is 18 of
course you could multiply 27 by
two-thirds as well so that's the key
characteristics of a centroid now
talking about the orthocenter okay
that's where the three altitudes cross
and it depends on the type of triangle
that we're looking at here there's kind
of three different things that can occur
when it's a right triangle see the
altitude is you know you can think of a
triangles like a mountain right if you
climb up this mountain and somebody says
well how high above the ground are you
you would measure straight down that's
your altitude okay
so in this case you can see the altitude
lines right along the edge of this
triangle if I was to take this triangle
and rotate it okay or if I was looking
from this vertex perpendicular to the
opposite side this is an altitude and if
I rotate it again sometimes it's hopeful
a nice sheet of paper just to think this
is a mountain like I was saying but what
you're doing is you're going from the
vertex
perpendicular to the opposite side now
notice all three of these altitudes they
cross right at this vertex where the
right angle is so with the orthocenter
the three altitudes are gonna cross I'm
gonna say on the triangle when it's a
right triangle when it's an acute
triangle that angles are less than 90
let's draw the altitudes here so again
going from the vertex perpendicular to
the opposite side notice they're
crossing inside that's the point of kind
of currency the orthocenter and when
it's an obtuse triangle this sometimes
trick students a little bit when you
climb up this mountain here and you say
okay how high above the ground am I well
it's almost like you could think of this
as being like like water over here right
so you have to actually extend this this
opposite side here and you're going
perpendicular to that opposite side now
what you're going to have to do is
you're gonna have to extend that a
little bit further okay and same thing
here if we find from the vertex
perpendicular the opposite side extend
that okay and then same thing over here
we'd have to go from this vertex
perpendicular the opposite side we're
gonna have to extend this side and
should again you know this is just a
rough drawing perpendicular you can see
it there crossing outside when it's an
obtuse triangle so those are the key
characteristics if you want to see how
to actually do these constructions with
a compass and a straightedge follow me
over to that video right there and we'll
talk more about these